good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about five ways that you
can achieve happiness way number one is
my personal favorite I make sure to
stick around although to the end for my
thoughts and some bonus clips as well
and as always if you hear something that
really really resonates with you please
leave it in the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well things getting things
is not gonna make you happy that's good
news in a tough economy it's a good
reminder you know doesn't matter what
you get doesn't matter whether it be
money or opportunity all those things
might excite you for the moment you know
even a relationship as magnificent it
may be might be exciting for a while but
if you don't keep growing that
relationship isn't gonna stay exciting
so the secret to real happiness is
progress progress equals happiness and
if we can make progress on a regular
basis we feel alive and that's why at
the beginning of the year we get this
thing like okay I can have this fresh
start I could really do what my soul
desires I could expand I could grow I
can improve I could change or maybe
better than change I could progress see
think about that progress is an
aliveness to it doesn't it you don't
have to work at changing people say all
the time that allow I'm working on
changing don't worry about it have to
work on changing changes automatic your
body's gonna change whether you want it
or not as the years go by you no matter
how hard you work there's gonna be some
changes going on there if the economy is
gonna change no matter what you want it
to do the weather is gonna change
relationships are gonna change
everything in life is always changing
we'll have to work on change change is
automatic but progress is not so if you
want to make real progress then you
really got to look at your life in a
different way you gotta say I gotta take
control of this process and not just
hope that's gonna work out like people
do who make a resolution happiness is
one of the most studied areas of human
endeavor
in the history of the world I mean when
you look at psychology and you look at
philosophy this is all I've been talking
about for literally centuries it's
unbelievable
so we've figured out the basics of
happiness it's that sometimes common
sense isn't common practice so people
struggle for no reason I mean look at
what we know about happiness you know we
know basically happiness usually comes
from an orientation towards the world in
which we look at the the past the
present and the future in specific ways
we often tend to look at the past with
gratitude and with fond recollection
even if there were struggles challenges
suffering turmoil we find our places in
the past and we feel a sense of
acceptance about the past it happened
it's good all things were as they were
and today there are as they shall be and
it's being okay with whatever the past
is finding a peace and acceptance and a
gratitude there allows us to be a little
more free in the present and being in
the present what makes us happy being
engaged in whatever we are really doing
I mean really engaged in it mentally
engaged in what we are doing each day
you know we're we were challenging
ourselves just a little bit you know
where we're finding something we're
passionate about interested in and
challenging ourselves to bring our full
conscious presence to the moment to
develop awareness right almost all
spiritual sort of texts and teachers and
trainers are always trying to help
people become just more present in the
moment more accepting of them as the
world as it is but here you know the
power of now is stuff right it's like
get here be here be engaged be present
with the moment and then with the future
it's all about anticipating with
excitement what's to come in the future
even if the future is scary even if you
know there's still going to be hardship
because there will be even if you know
there's gonna be struggle yep there will
be too but finding your marks what are
you excited about for tomorrow and if
you can't find anything to be excited
about tomorrow that has nothing to do
with the reality of tomorrow
it has to do with your mindset you've
poisoned yourself in pools of pessimism
for so long that you've drowned yourself
of hope that you've forgotten that there
is magic to life that there is something
tomorrow you could find something even
if tomorrow you just can say you know
what tomorrow I'm gonna get up I'm gonna
feel better just gonna decide to be be
excited about that you know tomorrow I'm
gonna go do something nice for somebody
tomorrow I'm gonna get focused in this
one project I've been waiting to do
tomorrow I'm gonna make the damn bed
whatever it is find something be excited
about for tomorrow that's the basics of
everything we know about your emotional
world and your mental world of happiness
so simple right and be accepting at
peace with the past be present and
engaged here in the present and be
excited anticipate something for the
future being happy is not difficult but
unfortunately most people don't manage
it because they think it's going to
happen to them when you have five years
of age you're quite happy isn't it yes
or no I want you to go home and see one
of your pictures when you're five it was
like this now it's becoming like this
when you're five years of age if you're
so happy by the time you're 30 you
should have been ecstatic if you had
grown I mean but by the time they are 30
most people are messed themselves up in
so many different ways this is not
because there is some difficulty with
life or happiness it is just that as I
told you they gave you a sharp knife you
don't have a steady enough hand if you
had a steady hand the sharp knife would
be a wonderful instrument if you don't
have a steady hand you keep cutting
yourself and now being happy when a
knife is constantly cutting into you
he's not he's very difficult for sure
yes how many times has it happened to
you in the last 25 years that it so
happened somebody put a knife into you
not happened for most of you if it
happened to one or two people I'm sorry
even nobody even put a pin in to you
isn't it so no I'm asking how many times
it so happened
from external sources suffering came to
you know you have mostly himself help so
no urine self-help isn't it
you don't need anybody's help you such
an expert sometimes when I see people I
think they're training to get employment
in hell or something they're practicing
here because they are so good at self
torture they may be good at up torturing
other people so happiness is neither
easy nor difficult because there is no
states like this this is happiness
this is unhappiness he was slipping
between this and that any moment isn't
it it's so more it's not like there is a
capsule of happiness and the capsule of
unhappiness and they're separate now it
is all intermingling one moment like
this one moment like in the same
situation one moment joyful one moment
miserable another moment some other way
is it not happening so these are not
anything this is just this you are a
volatile being right now not stable
enough I told you this evolutionary
problem your intellect and your
awareness evolved ahead of your
physiology your only one point two three
percent away from a chimpanzee but in
intelligence you are big away now your
own intelligence turning against you one
simple way of being happy is you go for
a lobotomy you know what this is they
mow half of your brain you will always
be like that so it's easy it's not easy
it's not difficult
should it be managed you don't have to
manage happiness you must learn to
manage your faculties you the only thing
is just this people are suffering two
most important faculties of your mind
your memory and your imagination which
sets you apart from every other creature
what happened fifty years ago you can
still remember which no other creature
on this planet can probably distinctly
and you can project into what may happen
in the next hundred years these
and imagination are two basic faculties
which makes us human and on top of the
evolutionary pile this is what people
are suffering
what happened 10 years ago they're still
suffering what may happen day after
tomorrow they're already suffering this
is not that they're suffering life they
just suffering their memory and their
imagination so happiness don't aim at
happiness just look at yourself how what
you call as myself is being conducted if
you conduct it if you know how to
conduct it the way you want it you will
be blissed-out yes it is not being
conducted so happiness and misery is
happening by accident somebody else can
cause happiness to you
somebody else can cause misery to you
people ask me such guru have you or we
have been with you for 25 years we've
never seen you angry do you ever get
angry you want it do I look like
somebody was incapable of something like
that if you want I will give you it's
just that I have not given this
privilege to anybody that somebody can
make me angry somebody can make me
unhappy somebody can make me happy now I
kept these things to myself
you must keep it to yourself - it must
be the best hands are you isn't it yes
your joy and misery must be in your
hands isn't it if you choose to be
miserable be I'm not against it but what
you want should be happening within you
not otherwise isn't it most people are
anticipating the day they'll be happy if
I do this that and the other thing so
horrible have it horrible focus on are
you momentary happiness not now there's
two types of happiness this is a long
conversation you don't only want
momentary happiness you sometimes have
to postpone present pleasure as an
investor to get something back later I
understand that but there's also the
other end of the spectrum that if you're
not liking most of your life make some
big changes if you like most your life
but not but there's a few little things
then you make little changes people
always ask me how do you know simple if
everything's [ __ ] then you have to
make huge changes usually there's
exceptions um if it everything's pretty
good just one thing gets on your nerves
you probably just got to change one
maybe two things but get to that place
where depressions diminishing even if
you have to do something dramatic even
if I have to quit a job even if you have
to move out from somebody you're living
with even if you have to spend less time
with the family member or you can't
sacrifice your happiness overall unless
you're investing so let's say for
example you go to the gym and you're not
that happy to be lifting weights because
it it hurts
well that's temporary pleasure that it
has a payoff very quickly any you know
your body gets healthier that kind of
pain you can keep around because there's
there's a gain to it there's the pain
and then the gain but a lot of us and
I've done this before you get to a place
where there's pain but there's no gain
it's just pure pain the fifth one is
about mindset and the mindset shift is
to appreciation because the truth is
oftentimes everything what we're trying
to get get get we're focused on what we
have and if you can shift your mindset
simply from not focusing on what I lack
but what I have and shift it from not
focusing on the bottom of that ladder of
the stuff but to the connection and the
growth that is the shift that will lead
to the most lasting happiness we have
access to this at all times of our life
even in the annoying moments when we're
standing in line it's 20 minutes to get
out of the food store you can focus on
the fact that you're 20 minutes late
what you don't have is your time or you
can focus on the fact that you have food
surrounding you from all kinds of the
world and you live literally better than
Kings did 100 years ago because they
couldn't get grapes right if you were on
the other side of the planet so
depending on what you compare yourself
to if you're alive today if you're
watching YouTube if you're on the
internet you literally live better then
Kings did not very long ago you are in
the top point one percent of lucky
people who have ever lived so no matter
what's going on in your life I know that
there will be things that knock you down
things that suck reasons to be unhappy
or there's always a reason to bounce
back if you shift your focus to what you
have compared to what you don't so I
hope you find that helpful I hope that
you can focus on what you appreciate if
you take one thing from this right now
write down or say in your head one thing
that is common to your life that is
little that maybe you don't notice all
the time that you appreciate right now
and I think that that I'll make you have
a much better day and you can keep it up
that habit will give you a much happier
life so I often get asked on the live
stream and also in life how I stay so
positive and how I seem so happy and
today might be a hard day his home I'm
feeling really sick but I am I am still
super happy and it comes down to two
things for me on the one hand it's being
grateful for everything that I have and
on the other hand it's wanting more and
doing work that I love and so on on the
one side you know being really grateful
for what I have I think it's important
that you think of and reflect on the
things that you do have in your life and
how fortunate you are just the fact that
you're watching this video you know you
have access to the Internet you probably
are eating food regularly you probably
live in a country that you know again
all of these things combined are way
better than what most of the world has
and so just reflecting on that daily I
think is important I've been doing the
daily gratitude practice for some time
now and
brought it to YouTube if you join me on
my other channel the live channel we do
it every weekday where we share for 10
minutes at 9:00 a.m. Eastern three
things that we're grateful for I think
it really makes a big big difference a
big impact cuz it's easier to just think
about what you don't have and that's
always a path to unhappiness
we're just reflecting on what you do
have can really have a big impact on
your happiness at least it has for me
and then on the other side I want to do
more I want to have a bigger impact I
want to help more entrepreneurs out I
want to make more videos I want to write
more books I want to do more speeches I
think doing work that you love and that
you really are connected to that you
look forward to going to do every day is
important for your happiness not that
every day is always amazing and you know
there's always gonna be battles and
bumps that you have to go through but on
the whole the work that I do is
enjoyable I like it like I'm making
these videos even though I'm sick
because I like it it makes me happy it
fuels me to know that I'm doing
meaningful work and so I think those two
things combined I think being really
grateful for what you have and
recognizing all of the amazing things
that you have that if everything went
away if it all ended tomorrow I couldn't
make any more videos I couldn't help any
more entrepreneurs I would still be
grateful for the impact that I've had
and everything that I have created
already and then I also want to go and
do more and they seem like opposite
forces but for me they balance each
other out and help me be happy on the
daily consistent basis so I hope that
helps you guys
now I made this episode of believe life
because Mason Larsen asked me to so if
there's a topic you'd like me to cover
in a future believe life please leave it
down in the comments below and we'll see
what we can do I'm also curious to
figure out what did you guys like from
this video what clip inspired you the
most what did you learn that you're
going to apply to your life or your
business somehow please leave it down
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion so thank you guys again for
watching I hope you have an amazing day
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
so start off by striving to become a
good person in his time
Aristotle examined the human condition
and came to a remarkable conclusion he
said only the good can be happy and only
the virtuous can be good now this is one
of the major breakthrough ideas in
philosophy imagine you can only be happy
if you're a good person and you can only
be a good person if you practice the
virtues that are associated with
goodness what this means simply is that
if you want to have a wonderful life
you must continually strive to become a
good person any deviation from this
course will lead you to lower levels of
happiness and dissatisfaction every
single time you act consistently with
the highest values and virtues that you
know you feel happy and strong inside
your self-confidence and self-esteem go
up and you become more effective in your
relationships and in your work that's
why they say virtue is its own reward it
pays for itself in the inner feeling of
pleasure and contentment you have when
you live consistent with the best you
know now let's talk about developing a
moral character in order to achieve
happiness and become a good person you
must know that character is the greatest
success factor of all if you want to
change your outer world you must go to
work like a computer programmer at a
keyboard to reprogram your subconscious
mind your world of values and beliefs
and inner convictions so that the person
you are on the inside is exactly the
mental equivalent of a life you want to
enjoy on the outside now in our world
your reputation is your greatest asset
your reputation can be defined as how
people think about you and talk about
you when you're not there as you know
from your own experience when people
talk about you in either positive or
negative terms and you find out about it
it has a major impact on your thinking
and on your emotions either positive or
negative because of the law of
attraction as you develop a moral
character and live more and more by the
highest and best virtues that you know
you will become a happy and good person
so you must always strive to exercise
this success factor and develop a high
moral character
you must compare everything you have to
do and say is this the right thing to do
and the rule is always do the right
thing and you always know inside what
the right thing is what Seneca is saying
is he's not and all the Stokes they're
not saying like you can't be wealthy you
can't be successful you can't go out and
do things what they're saying is that
you can't you can't be dependent on
these things like he's saying like
wealth is nice if you have it but if you
make your personal happiness dependent
on having this money that's bad because
it's not in your control right the
economy you could melt down at any
moment or your house could burn down or
you could lose your job and if you have
equated wealth with personal happiness
now your personal happiness is outside
of your control and so stoicism is about
control in that sense how do you how do
you make the distinction between
externals and internals and focus most
of your energy on internals having
externals is nice but sort of what they
would say is that understand that they
are yours in trust which means that they
could leave you at any moment and a lot
of the stoic exercises are sort of about
practicing not having those things so
Seneca was famous he one day a month he
would practice being poor so you'd wear
like crappy clothes and he would like
not eat at his house and he would sleep
outside and he would just I mean it's I
think more now like a metaphor than
anything else but the idea is like we're
so afraid of these things so we don't
think about them and therefore we're not
prepared for them and then it makes them
much scarier and we dread them that much
more even though if you looked at it
really objectively it's really not that
bad but she's worried about the rent
okay she's a single mother sure but her
kids a red [ __ ] you know and then you
could do about the rent worrying about
it now you gonna get you don't rent
presents and Happiness gets you rent
money can't make you happy but happy can
make you money so be happy go out in the
world with your story the guy in the
shanty house he rolls over in the
morning meditates goes out in the world
it's like damn I'm gonna have to get
some bread and water before the whole
[ __ ] go down before I get back in that
debt but the meantime be nice to all my
neighbors in the shanty village
everybody is suffering and what everyone
else calls extreme poverty but he's
happy didn't have a poverty mindset no
was he worried about that bread and
water they don't give me some
[ __ ] bread I don't worry about
that [ __ ] so now I'm that dude he walks
out smiling confident comfortable he
gets what he needs he says but Yogananda
would say God will provide but really
your God just working to get and it
shows up he gets his bread and water he
makes everybody happy everybody makes
him happy lays in the bed next [ __ ] he
wakes up he's got a you know you know 36
billion dollars in the bank he gets up
the stock market goes up he said oh [ __ ]
get some coke get some alcohol he gets
happy so excited I'm exploding I'm
making more money more money morning oh
[ __ ] it crashed
oh [ __ ] more cocaine more alcohol up
[ __ ] up [ __ ] up his heart goes up
and down and he dies at 40 the shanty
house guy lives in a hunt live to 100 if
he had the other guy's diet not the diet
other guy took but the other guy's
opportunity for have a greater diet the
guy in the shanty anthem it would have
made a hut in 20 but you know made 100
this guy died at 40 that's the reality
of all you know our happiness is up to
us you know our relationship with the
world is up to us our anxiety is
controlled or given to us by us